wir haben eine große sorgen weil wir
normalerweise 11 über 11.000 kinder
jeden tag versorgen wie dem frühstück in
ganz deutschland und das ist einfach
nicht möglich ist und wir finden keinen
weg zu den kindern zukommen wir wissen
dass die kinder natürlich diese sage
immer 11.000 kinder genauso wenig zu
essen haben wie sie normalerweise haben
wenn sie in die schule kommen und kein
abendessen hatten kein frühstück kein
pausenbrot und erst mittag zu essen
bekommen da kriegen sie von uns das
frühstück das ist das eine und das
andere ist dass unsere senioren die 1400
menschen die für uns arbeiten jetzt ja
auch ausgesperrt sind und wir nicht
wissen wie wir jetzt das auf die reihe
kriegen dass wir damit wir die kinder
wieder versorgen können dass die kinder
eben sich verlassen können sie gehen in
die schule holen sie von mir als die
hausaufgaben ab und nehmen einfach dann
in kästchen eine box mit wo einfach
essen drin ist und wir kriegen es im
moment einfach nicht gebacken
weil es natürlich so viele probleme gibt
es mir schon klar aber eben ich gehe
davon aus dass es eben diesen kindern
die immer not leiden die sowieso
abgehängt werden weil sie eben auch
nicht immer die hausaufgaben abholen von
der schule und dann auch nichts zu essen
haben und nicht keine wärme haben kein
geborgenheit fühlen ich also das ist für
mich ein so großes problem das sich über
andere sachen ehrlich gesagt im moment
das habe ich auch bei einem vorgespräch
gesagt mit anne sachen ob urlaub oder so
gar nichts anfangen kann weil ich so
unter druck stehe weil ich einfach weiß
wir können im moment nichts machen
wir haben natürlich auch nicht die
adressen weil wir beliefern ja die
schulen also ich datenschutz etc
wir kommen an die kinder nicht dran und
ich bin sicher es geht in so schlecht ja
ja ich glaube dieses problem wurde viel
zu spät erkannt ja erst heute hat man
hat sich ja die bundeskanzlerin mit den
ministerpräsidenten jetzt mal wirklich
konkret dieses themas angenommen und in
aussicht gestellt auch mal
entscheidungen zu treffen was die
schulen und was die kitas angeht genau
wie kinder aus der mittel die einzige
rettung hören ich spaßeshalber von
meiner überforderung zu hause sprecher
dagegen jahre hätten dann gibt es eben
all die anderen familien für die kinder
das einzige highlight ist eben in die
kita zu gehen andere kinder zu sehen und
spaß zu haben ja und die kinder segnet
sich nach schule ich meine das jahr über
so viel wie die wollen in die schwierige
im jahr weil das für viele kinder ihr
gewordenen raum ist ihr raum wo sich
wohlfühlen
lehrerin ist oder wo unser frühstück ist
und uns ist senioren die ein bisschen
familienersatz geben die antwort die
kinder auch mein arm nehmen und darf man
jetzt alles nicht aber sagen wir einfach
sagen wie geht's denn heute kommt setzt
sich erzählen mir was war denn los und
so diese ganzen geschichten können jetzt
wochenlang wochenlang nicht stattfinden
und wie gesagt ich habe aber dafür muss
er doch eine lösung gegen sie kann ja
auch nicht sein dass man jetzt die ganze
zeit darüber diskutiert ob wir alle
nachmachen können irgendwie in drei
jahren aber dass solche stationen hängen
bleiben und ich ja ich sage dir klagen
auf dem hohen niveau jeder darf bei sich
anfangen jeder darf sich gucken hat man
darf natürlich man muss auch so mal ein
bisschen abbott prioritäten setzen und
natürlich sind auch unsere politiker im
home-office stelle ich mir aber ein
bisschen anders vor als bei dir oder bei
mir im schlimmsten fall bei deinen
geschichten wir ja gerade deswegen
hatten ja auch die frauen zu wort kommen
und die mütter also ich hatte ja auch
wirklich darum wer dominiert gerade
diese corona debatte und die ist
sozusagen ohne dass ich da jetzt ein
keil zwischen treiben will schon auch
sehr männerlastig und ich finde es
wichtig ja dass auch mütter
alleinerziehende betroffene viel mehr zu
wort kommen und dabei berücksichtigt
werden die familienministerium
ministerin frau gefragt hat ja einige
vernünftige vorschläge gemacht
es braucht eine lobby auch für kinder
[Musik]